the president and Democrats are on a
collision course over that border wall
and how to pay for it
the president tweeted yesterday that
Mexico will be paying in some form for
the badly needed border wall but he says
the u.s. cannot start building it
without money from Congress Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill with the fight that
could force a government shutdown Nancy
good morning good morning and even some
Republicans are wondering if this is
really the time for that border wall
funding fight but the White House is
adamant it wants 1.4 billion dollars as
a down payment in that funding bill
Democrats are digging in and if this
isn't resolved by the end of the week we
could be looking at a shutdown building
a wall is not an answer not here or
anyplace Democrats in the House and
Senate said Sunday they will not support
a bill that includes funding for a
southern border wall it's a political
stunt an obsession for the president
that should not shut down our government
we will build a Democrats argue that
president Trump's repeated campaign
promise did not include a multi-billion
dollar bill for the American taxpayers
and Mexico will pay for the wall
publicans say the other side is writing
off the proposal too quickly I would
wish the Democrats would put aside
political correctness realize that
there's nothing racist or bigoted about
having a border wall Senate Republicans
have three days to pass a bill that will
fund the government through September
they need support from at least eight
Democrats to hit a 60-vote threshold in
the Senate so far no Republican lawmaker
from the four states along the us-mexico
border has expressed support for the
funding request the last thing we can
afford is to send a message to the world
that the United States government by the
way is only partially functioning
Florida Republican Marco Rubio told Face
the Nation his party should table the
wall for next year's funding fight I
think that's a fight worth having in a
conversation and debate worth having for
2018 and many Republicans frankly
weren't expecting to have this debate so
soon this spending bill only funds the
government through the end of the summer
in the meantime there are plenty to get
to work
a spending bill to fund the next fiscal
year and they'll have more time than
Nora to add and subtract more
flexibility and more time to horse-trade
there you go thank you Nancy